well I wasn't planning on doing a video
today but yet here we are down at the
bottom of the garden of the greenhouse
and it is a lovely lovely day I don't
know if you can quite see there but the
the automatic windows wide open which
shows you just how warm it is in here it
is beautiful I was out playing golf on
Thursday and it was horrible it was wet
it was windy it was a bit wild it was
awful but today is wonderful so I've got
two jobs I need to do today first job I
need to putt on the tomatoes remember
couple of weeks ago I was a little bit
late getting them started but they're
coming along they're looking okay
they've been under the grow light I've
had a bit of a dodgy setup sort of going
on inside so they need to go in the
proper groer but thing we've got
upstairs in their own little individual
cell trades because they'll come on
Leaps and Bounds from there and I'll
keep potting them up and moving them on
and get them going because it's only
going to be about I don't know 4 to 6
weeks before it's time for putting them
outside in the poly tunel so it's not
long to go for that next job I've got to
do and it's honestly it might seem a bit
Bor but it's one of the most satisfying
jobs you can see done you might remember
again a couple of weeks ago we just
started transforming this bottom area of
the garden here tidying it up getting
some new beds in stuff like that but
what I did at the time was I sprayed
down this patio cleaner stuff that's
meant to take effect over time and it
has and I'll show you in a bit will take
effect but it needs jet washing so I'm
going to give it a bit of a jet washing
this afternoon and there's nothing more
satisfying I don't think quite sad
saying that but you know when you see
the P you're getting jet washed it's all
dirty then it gets clean and clean and
clean and it looks beautiful at the end
of it so we'll get on we've just got a
small section to do it's not going to
take ages but we'll get on with that in
a bit but without further Ado let's have
a look in here in the greenhouse
cauliflowers is looking good we started
off a lot of seeds I don't think I
filmed this I had a bit of a a seed
sewing frenzy but it's going okay let's
just pick this one here this one is some
Canter lettuce and you can see there
some good good germination we'll keep
the the little Lids on now I've got the
holes open on the top so there's some
egg getting in and out of there but
they're coming on nicely we've got some
brussels sprouts here as well two
different varieties looking good come
and gone all right there as well I'll
try not to trap them in the lid and I've
got one on that side as well but
everything is looking okay the beetro
over here is looking good the the
cauliflowers are coming along nicely
these are the the onions yeah I
mentioned these before the rinberg
onions and they're little they're we
they've not done much they're still
small I mean that they're okay they're
firm they're decent they're not floppy
they're not dying nothing like that
they're just not not grown very much and
I did I did mention in my last video I
wonder if it's maybe it's a something to
do with the compost so I gave them a bit
of a liquid feed earlier in the week so
we'll see we'll see if the pick up we'll
see if they go but I I don't know if it
is the compost cuz it's the compost I've
used for everything and the the Red
Barons that I put out are looking all
right here's the the squash that's just
germinated you can see it's absolutely
flying and everything else is coming
along go right the the other onions here
which ones are these again the bedf
Champions these were sewn a lot later
but you can see the size of them
compared to the rbur ones but it's the
same compost it's the same watering cuz
I water everything at the same time when
I come down they've had the same feed
and whatnot but who knows but anyway the
tomatoes are getting ped on today
speaking of the tomatoes they're all
back here on the Super 7 I brought them
along on the Super 7 we've had some some
great germination they come along nice a
little bit dry so they'll all need a
good water and afterwards as well I'm
going to do two different sorts of pot
on um I'll not take it through all of
them there's too many to do all of them
we'll do two different types show you
what I'm doing but we'll get swapped
around here with the other cameras and
stuff and we'll get some filming done
right so we're going with the old dual
camera set of again today hopefully it's
going to work well it seems to go down
all right when we do this in the
greenhouse and I'm going to S it see I'm
going to S the SM was in two different
ways you can see I've already done a
roll here why have I already done a roll
here because I've already filmed this
but I don't think the audio was working
properly so we're filming it again so
we've only got one row in the cell tray
so what you need to imagine now is me
filling the cell tray with all this
lovely compost down here now speaking of
the compost this is the melat silver
grow it's the one I use all the time for
all the sort of seedlings and things a
day all the sort of plants in and around
the house anything I grow from seed
anything I bring on any little plants I
don't use it generally as a Ru of thumb
at the alotment it's a bit expens
expensive you want to top of beds and
stuff like that M coat silver goats are
we bit expensive for doing that sort of
thing so maybe you think about a a
different type of compost for that but
we'll sew these on in in two different
ways and we'll we'll do these ones first
so we've got the black strawberry ones
and I say they're looking just a a touch
leggy I've not had the the grow light
set in the the perfect sort of
conditions cuz I've just been a bit just
a bit rushing and and and all over the
place and do and stuff but I'm going to
try and get these set quite deep inside
the cell tray and I'm trying to get them
deep set inside the cells for a reason
and if I just pick up this one here in
particular and let me show you this up
here if you can see that on the camera
there's lots of little hairs all the way
down the stem now what I want to do is
try and get as many of those little
hairs on the stem as deep as we can in
the cell tray so it to be quite near
this first set of leaves here so the
little sort of flat leaves here you can
see the ones that don't have much shape
to them they're the seed leaves and all
the little jaggy ones that you can sort
of see above that's the true leaves that
are coming on so if we get that stem
plant a knife nice and deep in theory
all those little hairs that are on the
stem will make beautiful beautiful roots
for it to make nice strong plants and
these ones um doing here are the black
strawberry and for those of you who saw
me sewing the tomatoes you will remember
that I made a bit of a bit of a mistake
with the black strawberry when I sold
two lots of Brad's Atomic grape and only
zero lots of black strawberry and I had
to go and fix it but once again thank
you to everybody who spotted that or
right about now and we be putting on
Brad's Atomic gripe thinking they are
black strawberry so thank you for that
so you can see there we've got these in
the Cel Tre now just by sheer chance
sheer look would have it on the Super 7
we've got seven of these little quarter
size sea trays with seven varieties of
tomatoes and the cell tray we've got has
seven rows of four so I'm going to take
four of each of these plants for me to
take on for myself but I need to plant
on some others and I'll come to that in
just a second there let me pop that down
and we've got these we've got some
yogurt cartons but what I need to do
first of all have I got my little My
Little Snips here is we just need to put
holes in the bottom now the reason I'm
doing yogurt cartons instead of my
normal plant pots or cell trays or
whatever is because the rest of these
plants aren't going to be for me and
I've me I've mentioned this just sort of
briefly once or twice before there you
go look you can see the the holes in the
bottom there so the the water can drain
through I've mentioned this briefly
before for that I'm part of a group here
in lintho called lintho family which is
part of the lintho Community Development
trust and it's all but help it's all
aimed at helping people grow their own
things at home learning how to do it
help them out loads of tips and stuff
like that we've got a fabulous Facebook
group that people can come along and ask
questions and learn how to do stuff but
twice a year we have events and the
first event we've already had which was
was it last month Cy seems like ages ago
now and that was a seed Swap and the
local allotment Association comes along
and they do some um seed potatoes as
well so they sell seed potatoes and we
do a seed swap both at the same time
fabulous event and we always follow this
up in May so it's around about the
second or third week in May we'll be on
L go High Street doing a Seedling
giveaway or or seed or plant giveaway I
should say some of them get quite big by
then so all these little extra plants
that I'm doing then I'm going to put in
the yogurt pots and I've got my my stack
of yogurt pots here I like to have a
yogurt with my lunch every day so if the
stock stocky yogurt pots cuz I'm not
wanting to give away my good plant pots
all my my plant pots that I've got over
here my plant labels and stuff in and
whatnot I mean I I will put a label in
these so we'll know what they are so I'm
not giving away random plants mystery
plants come and get mystery plants so
we'll not we'll not we'll not do that we
will label them but the yogurt pots are
brilliant because it's recycled it's
reused and hopefully the person who
brings on this this little plant can
stain here for ages then the person who
gets this can use it hopefully use the
OT to plant something else in once the
little tomato plants out of it well that
is job number one and kind of job number
one and a half done let me show you what
we've got we have got lots of tiny
little potted up tomato seedlings there
they all look a bit sad they always look
a bit sad when you put them up every
looks a bit sad they do need a good
drink they're going to go into a to a
gravel train we'll water them all from
the bottom the compass going to soak up
all that water give them a day to a good
a good watering Under The Lights a bit
of warmth and they look absolutely magic
I don't expect them to be in this cell
tray too long let me get nice and close
just so you can see the size of it there
the size of the cells that we're using
you know be lucky if they're in here for
2 weeks before moving them on again into
the next size up but it's the right way
to do it cuz if you give them too much
compost to get too much compost The
Roots don't grow very strong cuz the
roots don't have to go off looking for
nutrition at least when they're small
they've got to find where the nutrition
is then move them on move them on those
roots just keep on growing at the right
size plus you know behind shedule this
year but you can kind of slow down
growth if you keep them in the small
cells the small pots a little bit longer
than you need to you can slow down the
growth a little bit but I need to speed
things up at this time of year because
it's it's getting be beautiful outside
and we've got our little ones here for
the the seedling giveaway I know I was
just saying there about having too much
compost but these are these are going to
be freebies for people but they're all
the little yogurt pots and again sheer
coincidence there's two of each so
there's enough two yogurt pots for each
variety of tomato so we've got 14 little
tomato plants I'm going to do other
stuff I've got some Jiffy pellets over
there watch out for that coming first
time trying them trying something
different for the seed seedling giveaway
that we're going to be doing next month
going to grow stuff in the Jiffy pellet
so again I'm not giving away plant pots
using different things and different
ways of doing things anyway next job on
the list and the one I'm looking forward
to going to get outside let's go on
let's get some jet washing done so that
took a little bit longer than expected
it get so the horse pipe the big the
good horse pipe is blocked or something
it's not working so I've got my backup
horse pipe on the go but let me just
show you here this is the bit we're
going to do you might remember say last
weekend weekend before whenever it was
we sprayed all the cleaner down on it
and it's it's come up pretty good you
can see it's killed off all the Moss and
things that were on here but this is the
pressure washer look we've got the
double powerful nozzle thing on it it's
the first time using it as well I got it
I got it last year we not had a chance
to use it yet but I would love to show
you all but it's it's over there oh it's
hiding over there cuz the hose pipe
we're using is a bit shorter but what
I'll do is I'll pop a link Down Below in
the description and you can go and have
a look and see what it's like it came
from screw fix um I've had the cart show
on before I had a cart show one before
you know the yellow ones that you say
with not impressed didn't last very long
did an okay job didn't last very long so
I'm a little bit skeptical about the C
ones so we went for a different one of
screx one like I say I'll pop a link in
the description down below go and have a
look see what it's like but the most
important thing is does it work is it
any good well there's only one way to
find out
[Music]
job done let's have a look see how it
looks and it looks pretty wet it's
nowhere near dry but there is loads and
loads and loads of mud and dirt and
everything that's come off us I'm
looking forward to when it dries out
when it dries out I will come along down
here and show you this is the next bit
I'm going to do over here let me just
show you look at this this hasn't been
done for years I did one slab over here
just to show you the difference between
the two but I'm going to get the the
patio cleaner down on this it all needs
brush this bits of stuff all over
everywhere it needs brush needs all the
dirt away then it needs the patio
cleaner put down then it needs to be
left for a while then it needs to be jet
wash and yes in case you're wondering it
was very much an addition of boys with
the toys at marks lotman plot here this
afternoon filming by drone jet washing
with a new jet washer what more do you
want than on a beautiful Saturday
afternoon anyway that's me done for
today thank you for watching and
hopefully I'll see you on the next one
bye for now